Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
(grunting)
Ooh!
Oh, my God.
(Abbi)
Um, Ilana...
Yeah?
You just pulled a bag
of pot out of your vagina.
I know.
Why-- why would
you do that?
I do it all the time.
Honestly, it's the
safest way to travel.
Apparently, I have been
smoking this tainted weed
for I don't even
know how long.
I didn't mean that.
It's just
disturbing to me.
I don't-- I don't know
what to tell you.
It's in a bag.
And, you know, the "vaya-nya"
is nature's pocket.
It's-- it's natural,
and it's responsible.
I shouldn't even be
bumming off of you.
(Ilana)
Oh, who cares?
No, I'm an adult.
I should be buying
my own pot.
Wow!
Never thought this day
would come, you know?
I would be honored and
pleasured to facilitate this.
No, no, no.
None of your dudes.
I wanna get my
own pot, okay?
I'm not gonna be like holding my
mommy's hand while I buy drugs.
I can do this.
(Ilana)
You know what
I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna be a grown-ass woman
and do my taxes for once,
without my
mommy and daddy.
Get it, bitch.
I'm gonna call some
old college buds,
a buncha weed-heads.
Hit 'em up!
I'm gonna get
those taxes did.
I'll hop on the Q18, catch the
N and then transfer to the R,
and get home in a tight 95
'cause the G ain't runnin'.
Whoa!
Um, but it was because
someone jumped on the tracks
to kill themselves,
it was really sad.
Love ya, bitch!